and it was building and building then
you know the dance scene is kind of like
when you that's the climax but it's also
the first time I was like that's where I
really put myself out there and it was
so personal to me like everything I
everything every line on the film Jared
Hess wrote right but the dance was all
me he just wrote how he takes how many
takes did you do the dance well that was
just it was three takes three takes and
you came up with your own stuff that you
rehearsing on your own no no rehearse we
did like a little rehearsal of the first
like two acres right you remember the
dance I mean how do you not remember the
dance yeah it was uh it was just um yeah
it was just I just winged it it was just
all freestyle people lost it yeah they
loved it they loved it because you're
like this might
Jared and I were saying like you know
this dance better be
it's not just good but it's gonna make
or break hopefully it all culminates to
this moment
and if the dance isn't good because in
the movie The Audience loves it the the
high schoolers love it right and you
hope it matches the crap the real
audience watching it right so you're
hoping and after the dancing there's
that pause and the audience cheers and
then our real audience is cheering and
it was just like you know I felt like a
million bucks and I think after that
Jared was like okay I'm in the clear did
you feel like
um my life's changing right now
I mean had to I remember that feeling
when I was in high school and I would
admit show videos that I made right I
loved it I loved that feeling I would
show it to classrooms I would do class
projects and we put that up and it's
that feeling as a as a director you know
like or if any
if you're an actor or director
especially if you're the director or
producer you know you made the film
you get that high from just like this is
my audience and they're they're gonna
watch it and people are loving it and
you're doing it for you but literally
just watching this documentary on ilm
that we're watching the Star Wars and
these filmmakers like George Lucas
saying is like me and Spielberg and you
know Coppola you know we did like to
make movies for ourselves and a lot of
times like they're doing it to like you
know a lot of filmmakers go there like I
want to make the moves I want to make
but these I mean he admittedly is like
we are the filmmakers trying to make
movies for people the audience we want
to make movies for the others we want to
see yes we're going to enjoy it at the
same time but we want to wow we think we
know what audiences want and we want to
wow them right and I and that was just
part of like you know who I was and we
want to make something now Napoleon was
kind of a personal thing especially for
Jared you know he's making something
that he needed to make that for him
hoping
well I don't know if audiences are going
to like this movie right so anyways yes
I knew my life was going to change why
yes why